okay welcome to this video yeah so I got
four losses in a row so let's see can I
avoid can I avoid the fifth loss yeah 3
losses in a row is called long castling
four in a row is the Audi yeah the Audie
the like the German car brand and five
losses in a row would be Olympic rings
and they don't think six losses in a row
is called something but it's it it's not
very common yeah losing six in a row
okay people know if I've by now
everybody reads books nowadays so he
probably go see five no he doesn't okay
that's the old line with e5 it's not bad
just I think a little bit less precise
and then e five
yeah Quincy seven and pressure p 6 is
how it is normally played Bishop d6 now
let's put this on the side nitey tool is
coming shortly I think think even here I
haven't looked at this for quite a long
time so Knight to f5 is one of the one
of the ideas or rock g1 maybe night here
first now looking at their five square
ok he's taking yeah I can take with with
all pieces there ok I take with the
Queen that looks a bit shaky push up g
396 maybe Bishop takes is night maybe 95
or something
the unprotected State of this rook on
the one is a bit worrisome could be
could be a tricky tricky thing why am I
going if I go here okay I still do that
it looks a bit weird but I want to
protect the rook here and really play
night at five maybe I kept f4 even on a
very good day looks a bit strange for
this Bishop a ok I can go here now c5 I
did not expect my bishop is actually a
bit more secure their on c3 and he
weakened the d5 square as well yeah of
course that's that's possible but they
have then I can put the 90s but should
be five though hmm yeah my dark squares
are not not exactly ideal
cantique f6r but I don't know about that
maybe maybe this an ID f5 it's very very
tricky yep I can do this I hyh five as
possible yeah my bishop is not playing
this is really but a bit disconcerting
maybe it takes and Quincy tuned for
Bishop c4 next I wonder can you take on
be Julia it might be possible okay
didn't happen maybe it wasn't working
before opted to hear him they are my
development
why am i playing like a complete fool at
the moment is difficult right
I really play like a complete [ __ ] at
the moment I don't know what that is
look at the tomb okay so see form a
three send him back I know if Queen
before was the best move
okay so rock d1 maybe get get pieces
involved him finally YUM so Bishop c4 I
guess or something better and let's do
this
damn ok I can check now 95 I can take
this okay if he takes with the pawn
avenue q 1 check sorry at night h6
starting with this okay then you can go
to g7 really
to g7 really yeah it seems he can go my
morning I had a total hallucination to
be honest I thought I had something
totally different there wow that makes
the whole operation kind of strange
taking this if I cannot directly use
this Wow
thank you let's get rid of this to Kim
maybe Quincy farm I can shake me here
check
yeah five losses in a row that I don't
think I ever really managed that one and
it's very likely happening unbelievable
yeah just see form very easy all of it
yeah very easy endgame we know him my
night is even about to be trapped almost
yeah it is strapped it is stripped yep
well white resides Wow amazing yeah I
just it was just a bad game I don't know
I never never got anywhere here and had
no idea nothing kind of kind of strange
ok this is this is a debatable move sir
need weakens the dark squares but gets
my Knight to f5 probably it's not it's
not particularly good here okay you can
take on b2 as all that but I didn't see
an alternative what what am i doing yeah
yeah it's bishop there's much stronger
probably you should take me to hear this
has already felt quite good to be honest
but
yeah rook g1 is good for white check
yeah I had the feeling that this is
somewhat strange what he did but well I
I didn't see anything here in this game
yeah that looks quite okay especially I
mean I had some weird hallucination down
I really somehow us thought that this
diagonal is open which is kind of
telling that I'm not really in any shape
here any kind of shape take stakes gem
queen bee three is better and here i can
say grab a few k this I can take here
okay i didn't i didn't see that one oh
I'm sure yeah this is quite good
checking this and Queenie six I only
thought about queen bee a check instead
of Quincy phone but this is some check
this is some perpetual job kind of
fitting up that I didn't didn't see that
one as well so this makes it the Olympic
rings five losses in a row 10 great
thanks for watching